bonsoir alors nous
on me pose la question pourquoi je fais
de la recherche en physique fondamentale
la première réponse c'est le salaire
c'est vraiment très bien payé
si sûr et en fait la deuxième réponse
qui n'est pas aussi forte que la
première mais j'adore le cinéma j'adore
le cinéma et le cinéma de
science-fiction en particulier est bon
ben j'ai été élevé petit avec planète
interdite 2001 odyssée de l'espace
et puis vers 15 ans j'ai vu star wars
est là clairement je me suis arrêté du
côté obscur de la force
j'ai pas réussi à aller plus loin et en
fait je fais de la physique parce que ça
me permet d'aller à la frontière entre
science et science fiction
donc l'idée c'est que je vais essayer de
vous montrer un petit peu ce qu'on pense
comprendre ce qu'on est sûr de pas
comprendre et donc on sera tous ensemble
à la frontière de ce qui m'intéresse
alors ici je vais donc vous raconter une
histoire de l'univers on est assez
modeste jean physique on vous raconte
une histoire sur 13,8 milliards d'années
il faut le croire sur parole méfiez vous
des gens qui vous disent alors cette
histoire de l'univers elle s'étale sur à
peu près 13,8 milliards d'années entre
maintenant où l'univers est extrêmement
étendue très froid au moins 270 degrés
celsius plutôt vide
jean l'équivalent d'un atome d'hydrogène
par mètre cube
et puis grâce à plusieurs points les
trois piliers qui sont dessinés ici
qu'on appelle le big bang le modèle du
big bang
on arrive à reconstruire l'histoire
jusqu'à un point qu'on appellera le big
band
ces points sont l'expansion de l'univers
donc c'était contenues dans les
équations d'einstein
la solution qui a montré d'expansion
théorique ça a été fait par le maître
dans les années 20 25
et puis au bbl dans les années 28 avec
son télescope s'est aperçu que tout ce
qui était autour de nous s'éloignait
d'autant plus vite que c'était loin
c'est l'expansion de l'univers
la nucléosynthèse primordiale c'est le
fait que gamme ' physicien compris
comment quelque 100 secondes à partir de
ce qu'on appellera le big bang
les noyaux noyau simples comme le proton
peut devenir de l'hydrogène puis faire
du deutérium de l'hélium 3 2
car et c'est donc on a à peu près
compris comment fonctionnait la première
construction des noyaux atomiques
et puis au dernier point c'est le fond
diffus cosmologique ça c'est une mesure
qui a été fait dans les années 65 1965
par hasard par wilson et penzias et ils
se sont aperçus qu'on recevait un
rayonnement quelle que soit la direction
que regarde autour de soi
ce rayonnement extrêmement isotrope 10.5
très peu différences de températures
extrêmement faible et en fait il nous
renseigne sur ce qui s'est passé
quelques 380 mille ans après le big bang
c'est à dire quelque part par là là
l'univers était très chaud très dense
les températures de l'ordre de 10
puissance 17 kelvin
et puis il est devenu transparent 380
mille ans après big bang et on reçoit
encore la lumière aujourd'hui
donc ça c'est une histoire assez brève
de l'univers et je vais essayer de
partir de ce qu'on connaît dans cette
histoire de l'univers et je partirai de
cette image que j'imagine que tout le
monde a vu en troisième
c'est le tableau de périodique des
éléments
j'aime citer ce tableau parce qu'il a
été fait par man d'aliev qui était
vraiment un génie qui a réussi à voir
comment on pouvait ranger par colonne
c'est à dire par massa tommy croissante
et par ligne c'est à dire par propriétés
chimiques analogues
comment on pouvait ranger les 94 atom
pseudo stable qui nous entoure alors
j'aime citer principalement mains des
lièvres parce qu'il était un génie et
qu'il était il avait une barbe grise
mais il n'y a probablement pas de
corrélation
mais je tenais quand même a souligné ce
point là donc vous savez tous que ces
objets atom sa de ça vient du grec at
home insécables c'est raté ces câbles on
peut descendre dans l'atome et vous
savez tous ce qu en gros un atom ses
formes est bon pour le plus simple d'un
proton et d'un électron en fait d'un
noyau constitué deux protons de neutrons
et d'un nuage électronique nous tout
ceci est constitué de protons et de
neutrons et d'un nuage électronique
en fait en regardant de près on s'est
aperçu que les protons et les neutrons
était constitué de deux objets nous
dirons plus petits le terme plus petit
ne s'applique pas forcément mais ça fixe
les idées en tout cas il ya une sous
structure aux protons cette structure
avec deux quark de charges fractionnaire
je peux construire soit un proton de
charge électrique 1 soit un neutron
neutre
j'ai parlé d'électrons tout à l'heure et
puis je rajoute une dernier objet qu'on
appelle le neutrino le trio ça a été
prédit théoriquement par un physicien
poli qui a dit bon moi je veux conserver
la conservation d'énergie genre
lavoisier rien ne se perd rien ne se
crée tout se transforme donc les gens en
physique sont assez attaché la
conservation d'énergie
il a dit baum a comme il ya un problème
il ya forcément une particule qui existe
et il a fallu attendre 26 ans pour
l'observer donc je viens de vous décrire
à travers ce qu'on appelle les quarks
qui constituent les protons et neutrons
les leptons qui constitue en partie le
nuage électronique la totalité de ce que
ce qui est destiné à gauche ici sur la
table de mendeleïev en fait en regardant
de près c'est à dire en regardant les
rayons cosmiques
ensuite en faisant des mesures sur
l'accélérateur on a fini par comprendre
qu'ils avaient pas une seule famille
mais trois familles les deux autres
familles sont en fait plus lourdes se
désintègre systématiquement dans la
première famille mais disons que ça ça
représente les briques élémentaires et
vous comprenez bien pourquoi les
chimistes sont des travailleurs puissent
qu'ils apprennent 118 objets et que le
physicien est un gros paresseux il a
réussi à simplifier le bazar sur 12
douze éléments alors bon j'ai des
briques élémentaires il faut bien qu
elles interagissent entre elles
alors on parle de force mon physique on
parle plutôt d'interaction on l'a
observé on en connaît quatre alors
probablement qu'il y en a peut-être une
cinquième et une 6e qui compense
parfaitement la 5e et comme je vous le
voit pas on va rester à quatre
et donc ces quatre là la gravitation
j'imagine que vous connaissez je prends
la jeune fille qui est face à moi je la
jette en l'air elle retombe d'accord
l'interaction électromagnétique on a vu
tout à l'heure grâce à monsieur combien
c'était important pour pouvoir
communiquer via plaisant marché je
m'excuse
bon ok l'interaction électromagnétique
l'interaction faible interaction fait
tout le monde connaît la radioactivité
les centrales nucléaires bon moi je dois
voir du potassium 40 ça se désintègre en
permanence je vous inondent de neutrinos
d'anti neutrinos tout ça n'est pas très
grave
donc en fait c'est au sein d'un noyau le
tronc se transforme en proton plus
électrons plus antineutrino et puis
l'interaction forte
l'interaction forte en fait c'est celle
qui permet de maintenir les couacs au
sein du proton est en fait l'ensemble
des protons au sein d'un noyau en fait
on peut dans la mesure où on fait
l'hypothèse qu'on regarde tout ça dans
une distance inférieure aux radios au
rayon du proton donner des estimations
de l'intensité si c'est un pur
l'interaction forte c'est le pur sang
pour l'interaction électromagnétique et
c'est le pour 10000 pour l'interaction
faible ce qui va pas très bien dans ce
que je vous raconte c'est que la
gravitation arrive dans ce schéma à 10 -
38 1-0 virgule vous mettez 37 0 et 1 1
l'impact de la gravitation sur les
éléments microscopique est pas clair bon
négligeable on ne voit pas on oublie
donc en fait c'est un petit peu de mal à
rentrer dans dans la description des
forces telle qu on la comprend
aujourd'hui et comment on comprend une
interaction force ou une jour
aujourd'hui c'est en fait à partir mans
vous avez deux objets deux électrons en
électrons à quartz peu importe ils
interagissent à travers une force par
exemple l'électromagnétisme et en fait
c'est un échange de messages et qui va
passer d'un objet à l'eau
donc pour l'électromagnétisme le message
et c'est le photon tout le monde le
connaît gens soient pleins les yeux
je renvoie quelques-uns en ce qui
concerne l'interaction faibles ils sont
au nombre de trois w plus - et z c'est
des objets assez massif puisque tout a
lieu à l'intérieur du noyau c'est de
l'ordre d'une centaine de masse d'un
proton et puis les gluons bon le nom me
semble clair plus on colle ça permet aux
protons de rester dans un boyau quark
d'être collé dans un proton reste
gravitons qui pourrait être si je
gardais cette description ici le
messager du la force gravitationnelle
mais on n'a pas encore observé ces des
hypothèses et jean travaille dessus mais
pour l'instant ça n'est pas sûr que ça
existe alors je vous ai décrit la
matière alors j'ai fait un code couleur
je sais pas si vous avez vu vous avez
alors plutôt bleu la matière ensuite
plutôt rouge les forces
tout était parfait dans le meilleur des
mondes possibles dans les années 60 mais
il y avait une prédiction de ce modèle
qui marche plutôt bien les gens étaient
contents
sauf que ça prédisait que tous les
objets et s en masse alors il se trouve
que le photon et ce en masse donc on
était contents on avait un juste mais
tout le reste est faux donc c'était un
peu ennuyeux dans les années soixante
quatre pour être exact peter ixe au
teint clair et d'autres physiciens ont
impliqué un mécanisme qui préexistait en
physique et en mathématiques qu'on
appelle la brisure de symétrie qui
arrive au moment des transitions de
phase alors une transition de phase
c'est hyper simple j'imagine que tout le
monde a déjà fait bouillir de l'eau et
donc si tout le monde a fait bouillir de
l'eau il s'est aperçu que à la surface
de l'eau au moment où sa bouille à la
fois de la vapeur et du liquide il ya
donc un échange permanent vapeur liquide
aux mêmes mécanismes si jamais je fais
un glaçon liquide aux glaces durant
cette transition de phase en fait vous
voyez c'est un changement de température
tout à l'heure je vous ai dit que
l'univers il ya très longtemps il était
petit dense et très chaud est due à
l'expansion de l'univers
eh ben il s'est refroidie et donc il ya
eu plusieurs transitions de phase dans
l'histoire de l'univers
et y en a une qui on peut expliquer à
travers une brisure de symétrie
mécanisme mathématiques qui en
particulier prédit l'existence d'une
nouvelle particule et la nouvelle
particule on l'appelait x du fait que
monsieur pieter ickx été parmi les
premiers à la supposée et donc on a mis
à peu près une cinquantaine d'années à
l'observer ça a été prédit en 64 et on
l'a observé en 2012 alors je vous ai
fait une petite figure ici 80 100 120
140 160 c vous imaginez fois la masse du
proton donc l'objet jaune là étant aux
environs de 125 fois la masse du proton
ce qui est intéressant dans cette courbe
c'est que en rouge il ya ceux qui est
prédit par la théorie avant l'existence
du boson de higgs en petit point noir ce
sont les mesures qui ont été faites dans
les expériences donc ici on voit que ça
marche pas trop mal on voit que ça
marche bien ici et puis là on voit que
les points noirs sont quand même assez
loin de la courbe rouge
par contre si je rajoute le boson de
higgs je remplis cette case là et donc
je obtiennent j'obtiens un modèle
parfaitement cohérent mathématiquement
prédictif et donc je ne réussis plus ou
moins comprendre disons ceux qui
m'entourent alors ça c'est juste pour
les gens qui seraient intéressés de
savoir à quoi ressemble à boson de higgs
donc on a fait un appareil photo 45
mètres de long 25 mètres de diamètre il
prend des photos toutes les 25 nano
secondes donc rapidement tous les 25 10e
de seconde
là vous avez probablement à boson de
higgs
parce que on n'est pas capable de savoir
exactement du fait que la nature et
probabiliste à 80% c'est probablement un
boson de higgs
en tout cas les produits de
désintégration d'abandon de higgs ici
c'est en quatre murs les traces bleues
évidemment on apparaissent pas
directement aux mesures dans les
différents détecteurs des petites
informations rouge orange ensuite un
logiciel reconstruit les directions et
on reconstruit l'objet qui a été à
l'origine de ces objets d'art et donc
ses photographies en première
approximation dabo android donc durant
ces douze minutes j'ai beaucoup de
retard je vous ai totalement décrit ce
que je crois comprendre la matière les
forces et ça ça décrit tout vous - les
araignées les étoiles
peu importe et c'est là que ça se gâte
parce que ce que je vous ai décrit c'est
ce que je comprends d'un point vue
rayonnement sa également un impact
gravitationnelle à travers par exemple
si je regarde les planètes on est autour
du soleil mais il se trouve qu'il ya pas
que ça qu'il ya comme un pacte
gravitationnelle autour de nous et ça
c'est juste une petite courbe pour vous
rappeler que si je regarde la vitesse
des des planètes en fonction de leurs
distances au soleil plus je suis loin
plus je tourne lentement donc ça c'est
ce que newton et einstein naturellement
tombe sur ce genre de raisonnement
il se trouve que dans les années 30
d'abord par un monsieur qui s'appelait
zwicky 70 par une astrophysicienne qui
s'appelle verra ruby les gens se sont
dit on va regarder comment tourner mais
les étoiles dans une galaxie par exemple
nous notre soleil il fait du 220 km
seconde dans la voie lactée
mais quand vous avez une belle galaxie
vous pouvez faire la même chose étoile
par étoiles en fonction de la distance
de leur vitesse et vous obtenez une
courbe comme ça qui n'est absolument pas
celle qu'on attende est en fait il ya
plusieurs types de mesures qu'on peut
faire elles sont au nombre
principalement de quatre essais et
mesures tendent à nous faire à nous
convaincre que en faites ce que je vous
ai décrit ne représentent que 16 % de la
matière en termes d'impact
gravitationnelle est que j'ai 85 % dont
je n'ai absolument aucune idée de la
provenance
c'est là que ça se gâte
parce que déjà je viens de vous dire que
je comprends pas 85 % de la matière qui
m'entourent pas très compétent le type
bon maintenant il se trouve que grâce à
instyle je peux essayer d'estimer le
contenu en énergie de l'univers enstein
ces équations ça se résume par en fait
la courbure de l'univers est
proportionnelle au contenu en unis en
énergie l'univers donc simon transparent
représente 100% d'accord je viens de
passer quelques minutes à vous décrire
la matière qui rayonne et qu'un appât
gravitationnelle la matière qui rayonne
pas en tout cas je suis pas foutu de le
mesurer et qui a un impact
gravitationnelle très notable et
le reste je sais pas ce que c'est alors
quand on sait pas en physique on dit
d'arc c'est pas mal dont dark matters
genre en matière sombre dark energy
énergie sombre dark vador non c'est même
bon il ya aucune raison que vous ayez
que vous deviez me croire alors je vais
essayer quand même pas recette cette
image de vous convaincre qu'on fait des
mesures à différents moments de
l'histoire de l'univers et que ces
mesures nous conduisent à cette
conclusion
alors vous avez ici une image qui vont
train pelote qui monte à batié entre 0 %
et 1 %
l'énergie sombre entre 0 % et 1 % et
puis ici des couleurs orange ça revient
ici vers la et bleu ces mesures là ça
c'est le fond diffus cosmologique c'est
le fait que j'aie un rayonnement
permanent qui me tombe dessus et grâce à
cette mesure je fais des des calculs
assez précis j'arrive à définir dans le
plan matière dark energy cette bande
orange cette image est intéressante
aussi parce qu'elle me dit quand je
regarde les galaxies qui sont autour de
moi
jusqu à un certain moment dans
l'histoire de l'univers elles sont pas
distribués aléatoirement
elles sont toutes distribuées avec en
moyenne une distance de 100 dans une
unité astrophysicienne idiote et
incompréhensible mais on s'en fout
ce qui compte c'est que j'ai un pic ici
et que donc il ya une anisotropies
claire de la distribution des galaxies
aujourd'hui il se trouve que c'est
anisotropies ici est strictement
identique à celle qu'elle a c'est le
cayla est à 2 380 mille ans après le big
bang
cela c'est entre 0 les 6 milliards
d'années joie et donc en fait on a une
espèce de grande cohérence entre les
anisotropies ici et là les halles
isotropique eux voyaient entre les
points rouges et les points bleus est de
l'ordre de 10 - 5
donc c'est vraiment très faible mais du
fait de l'expansion de l'univers
on tombe là dessus dans les années 90
les gens ont observé ce qu'on appelle
des supernovae à différents âges de
l'histoire de l'univers et se sont
aperçus que l'univers n'était pas
seulement en expansion mais il était en
expansion accélérée
toujours est il que si vous prenez ces
trois mesures qui ont lieu à différents
moments de l'histoire de l'univers
le vert le bleu le orange vous tombez là
dessus et on tombe sur 70% d'énergie
sombre et 30 % de matière c'est prendre
pour cent de matières contiennent à la
fois la matière qui rayonne que je crois
comprendre et la dark matters que je ne
comprends pas donc si je résume 5 % de
ce que je crois avoir compris vous moi
les étoiles 26% bon je travaille dessus
il faut pas quand même comme je tire une
balle dans le pied mais bon on va dire
qu'on pseudo comprend en tout cas on en
voit les effets indirects et on espère
faire un pas en avant
et alors ça alors là on est dans un pâté
noir si j'ose dire bien sûr
donc j'ai l'impression quand même que je
suis dans laxe du ryveld the unknown je
vous ai révélé que je ne comprenais rien
et
[Applaudissements]
c'est très gentil et je terminerai juste
par une phrase très importante pour moi
méfiez-vous des asthmatiques comprenne
qui pourra
merci
[Applaudissements]